de la sobriété c'est le mot d'ordre pour
le cinquième anniversaire du parti la
république en marche coville 19 oblige
les membres du parti souffleront leurs
cinq bougies virtuellement sur le papier
elle rer va bien avec une petite fortune
de 23 millions d'euros au titre des
aides publiques allouées aux partis
politiques et plus de 400 mille
adhérents revendiqués
à noter que ces derniers ne sont pas
obligés de payer de cotisations pour
autant si la crise sanitaire ne permet
pas l'organisation de festivités
le bilan en demi teinte du parti non
plus c'est en tout cas ce qu'a confié un
proche du chef de l'état à nos confrères
du quotidien le parisien la crise
sanitaire est passée par là
les français sont à nouveau confiné et
notre économie tourne au ralenti faire
une grande fête dans un moment pareil ça
paraît très franchement déplacé
on va se prendre une taule aux
prochaines régionales après celles des
municipales et le pen est au coude à
coude dans les sondages pour 2022 alors
il faut dire que le parti du chef de
l'état qui porte ses initiales présente
quelques failles
à commencer par sa faible présence à
l'échelon local et l'échec subi lors des
municipales en est probablement une
conséquence malgré ce constat selon l'un
des porte parole de la république en
marche
le parti aurait malgré tout la capacité
de survivre aux scrutins locaux
oui on n'est pas ancrée dans les
territoires mais nous avons une capacité
à porter les forces militantes une
dynamique une agilité qu'on peut nous
envier
et qui peut nous permettre de survivre
aux élections bilan en demi teinte aussi
du côté de la représentation
parlementaire des 317 députés aient
l'air m présent en 2017 à l'assemblée
nationale il n'en reste plus que 2 169
conséquence plus de majorité absolue
cette dernière nécessitant 289 sièges
parmi les défections on peut par exemple
citer celle de mai 2020 17 députés issus
de l'ailé gauche du parti dont matthieu
orphelin et paula forte à forment le
groupe écologique
mocratie solidarité faute d'un nombre de
membres suffisant le groupe et 10 ou 5
mois plus tard puis c'est le numéro deux
du parti pierre person qui a tiré sa
révérence en septembre dernier en 2018
j'avais fait le choix de l'unité de ma
famille aujourd'hui le parti a besoin
d'un nouveau souffle
c'est pour initier ce sursaut que je
décide aujourd'hui de quitter mes
fonctions au sein du mouvement des
défections qui pourrait aussi se
répercuter lors des régionales en juin
prochain des conseillers régionaux du
modem envisagerait d'apporter leur
soutien à valérie pécresse plutôt qu'aux
candidats de la république en marche en
ile de france et ce alors que le modem
est l'alliée du parti des mesnel macron
au niveau national en décembre dernier
déjà le délégué national d'agir partis
alliés de l om avait soutenu valérie
pécresse